[Music]
welcome to Eugene Oregon the small city
of 160 thousand people has long been
home to iconic individuals and products
you've got Prefontaine Nike and Ken
Kesey my personal favorite Merry
Pranksters and now this hotbed of
unconventional thinking has cooked up
another surprise this is the our Komodo
[Music]
it's a three wheeled all-electric
vehicle that's meant to revamp
transportation and cities it's cute it's
fast and after 11 long years of
development you can even buy one the big
question now is how many people actually
will
[Music]
the Okimoto is the brainchild of this
guy mark Frohnmayer he called it a fun
utility vehicle that's you guys do call
it a [ __ ] it's their fuv the fuff all
you need is five there's a card-carrying
Pacific Northwest tree hugger mark set
out to create an electric alternative to
the gas guzzling behemoths most of us
drive all you really have to do is just
stand on a busy street corner and watch
the cars going by it's just over and
over and over you see one person
traveling with a relatively small amount
of stuff traveling a short distance and
yet we use these way overcapacity
devices to do that I wanted to really
find like what is that sweet spot that
is much much more efficient than a
full-size car and would help start to
move the needle on the climate problem
that we've got
and so give me the specs on the air
kimono how fast is the battery last zero
to 60 in seven and a half seconds 80
mile an hour top speed our initial
launch version is gonna have right
around 100 mile range and then target
price of around 12 grand all right what
do we have in store today we're gonna go
rip around town on the fun utility
vehicle give me the Eugene tour like
that you know the nascent tech an
automotive capital of the world
[Music]
this is downtown right here such as it
is this is metropolitan downtown Eugene
Oregon and you grew up here where'd you
grow up I grew up here Eugene Eugene I
don't mean to be cliche about it but
there are cannabis stores everywhere I
mean it's legal where I live - but this
is this is the whole thing
the vision of a pot shop on every block
is being fully realized here in Eugene
before starting our comodo mark led a
very different sort of life as a star
video game designer he made a small
fortune when he sold his company garage
games in 2007 and he still likes to come
to retro arcades like this one to blow
off steam are you gonna be here for like
two hours then ultimately I do want to
go after the world record like a million
nakamoto's you can I really then I want
to do something with my life
what was your hip game at garage games
probably the most well-known game that
we did at garage games was a serious
called marble blast and I got installed
in like every lab for a long time it was
on every iMac in every MacBook so you go
for blood you build a gaming company in
six years you said it was and go from
like nothing to make a No we all put in
10 grand and we sold the whole thing
total deal was 50 million 50 million
okay I was convinced I could obviously
do anything because first it's like you
get you play baseball first time at bat
you're like homerun while baseball is
easy found out that there are different
types of companies some are much harder
than others
over the past 11 years our comodo has
had tons of ups and downs
including times when the business ran
out of money and had to pause it's been
brutal we've been to the brink and
beyond multiple times but then we would
look out of the world and say well has
anyone else really cracked this problem
yet I guess not
so let's let's try again last year
things started looking up the company
went public and raised enough cash to
pay for this Factory and soon it will be
possible to zip around town in an arc
Emoto of your very own what is it worth
it to truly test out the fove one must
live as real Eugene OR or Eugene i'ts do
that means running a very important
errand
[Music]
now I'm not saying I smoked any weed
while doing such important journalism
but how are you thank you what do you
think of my called an ARCA moto with an
electric car
cravings satisfied I had one final test
for mark I've got one last question for
you all right this is the hardest one
okay do you want to go full Elan so save
that for the off-camera you made the
wise choice thanks for watching and if
you want to see more hello world click
on the link to subscribe